[Música]
a satisfação está aqui uma alegria está
com todo mundo pra falar de um tema que
eu tenho um carinho enorme que é
folclore
eu queria começar perguntando na verdade
é que dá pra ver a platéia quando fala
folclore qualquer a primeira coisa que
vem na mente que vocês pensam um
pouquinho eu já imaginei olha quem
pensasse só fazer uma enquete aqui
mula-sem-cabeça curupira o saci é
campeão disparado com mais de 90% e ele
ganha no primeiro turno sossegado dos
outros dos personagens mas e é curioso
sem colocar no google
na pesquisa de imagens folclore as dez
primeiras páginas vão ser só com
personagens de lendas do nosso folclore
mas a minha pergunta é será que foi
agora só lenda que ele se resume a isso
além das e aí que foi a reflexão o
folclore na verdade esse termo foi usado
pela primeira vez em 1846 pelo
arqueólogo inglês william john thoms no
dia 22 de agosto
por isso que é comemorado o dia do
folclore 22 de agosto ea tradução de
folclore seria sabedoria popular
conhecimento popular folclore são todas
as características são saberes dos
conhecimentos são passados de tradição
de geração em geração é todos os
costumes que caracterizam um povo que
caracteriza uma comunidade é o que nos
faz entender como pertencentes a um
lugar
as lendas fazem parte disso nelas também
mas o problema é que elas não são só
isso
essa é a questão ea gente tem o costume
de reduzir o folclore a lenda e aí a
gente cai num problema que eu queria que
pensassem comigo
o folclore e pegou um sentido pejorativo
muitas vezes a gente associa folclore
com coisas passadas com coisas que não
existem mais que a mentira pode ver quem
frases de gente pode usar isso é quando
ele comenta a
para o deputado isso é folclore isso não
existe mais é balela a um determinado
time a esse é folclore ou alguém conta
uma história pra você falar não é fofoca
no sentido de mentira falso algo de tão
esquecido ao que não existe mais um
pouco ao contrário disso essa que é a
parte triste da história foi claro o
folclore é vivo o folclore está presente
é dinâmico e ele está no nosso dia a dia
ea gente infelizmente tem a tradição de
pensar e distante né
já pensaram que o folclore pode estar
presente nas coisas que a gente faz
vamos tentar pensar assim já que
populares que caracteriza um povo
o que será que crê que a gente podia
pensar no nosso dia a dia uma coisa
próxima que poderia caracterizar o
brasileiro né ou a nossa comunidade ou a
gente como paulista como mineiro como
que a gente poderia se identificavam
pensar em coisas simples não distantes
muito próximo da gente pensar na comida
a gente tem os pratos tradicionais
brasileiro pode falar para tapá feijoada
moqueca uma receita de pão de queijo uma
pamonha
vamos pensar muito próximo mesmo alguém
imaginou arroz feijão
ninguém está pedindo que sejam o arroz
feijão se pensava com uma comida mais
brasileira que elas sejam
você pode viajar viajar de norte a sul
do brasil se for um restaurante
dificilmente não vai ter uma voz feijão
de corda sempre vai dar de presente né e
quando você está comendo arroz feijão se
alguém já pensou assim nossa tô aqui
celebrando o folclore nacional de
alegria dele dia 22 de agosto
vou fazer aquele arroz feijão vou
preparar porque não vamos celebrar nossa
cultura não aquilo é natural você faz se
com eles viajam sem ficar pensando
aquilo faz parte de você
um outro um outro e mas tem certeza se
alguém um dia viajar para fora do brasil
vai sentir muita falta do arroz feijão
porque faz parte da nossa essência
a gente sente em casa então quando você
está fora não tem isso perto de você
você vai sentir distante só vai sentir
longe de casa e outros ainda como não
pensar no nosso costume
se alguém dá um espirro aqui que é o
crime foi alguma coisa pra saúde né e
outro responde o que a man alguém
ensinou pra gente isso um dia na escola
se pegou uma tabela ao todo brasileiro
quando um outro brasileiro espirrar
o brasileiro lado obrigatoriamente pra
você tem que falar saúde e um outro em
resposta ao crescimento flamengo não
fala isso a gente viveu isso
naturalmente é passado para a gente
você vê no isso acontecer né isso faz
parte da nossa essência
não sei se acontece com vocês mas alguém
espirra ninguém fala nada para fazer no
enem sujeito por outro lado aquele
silêncio me dá uma agonia desesperadores
não viu de saúde
esse outro responde o homem jesus né
lamenta sendo substituído pelo obrigado
estamos acompanhando um pouquinho a
transição mas isso faz parte não sei se
alguém chegou na sua casa oferece um
cafezinho ou se aceita um café né
todos os bons costumes ou receita da sua
avó né a nossa riqueza de música de
dança que a gente tem
os ritmos tradicionais maracatu samba
jongo congada folia de reis catira as
duplas tradicionais caipiras
o brasil é um dos países mais ricos em
diversidade de música e dança disparado
então a gente tá e isso não está morto
isso não está esquecido isso é passado e
seu folclore vivo é presente quando
alguém espirra ou fala saúde está
fazendo isso é a nossa essência ocorre
não está parado ea gente muitas vezes
imagina esse folclore distante né
e a gente tem uma tradição infelizmente
o que que é isso aí de de negar nossa
nossa essência de negar a nossa tradição
de negar as nossas manifestações
culturais
isso tem por paulo parte da população e
um dos aspectos principais eu acredito
que é pela falta de conhecimento mesmo
de saber que existe de valorização
essa dessas tradições e por pais também
do do nosso poder público por parte do
estado que não cuida das tradições né a
gente ainda tem o brasil é muito
precário nisso o governo deveria olhar
com mais carinho olhar dando apoio da
manutenção para todas as comunidades
pelos mestres os artesãos os músicos que
preservam as tradições populares porque
isso porque são nessas pessoas que está
a essência da nossa identidade
se o folclore morre
a gente deixa de de ser um povo com
característica que nenhuma árvore é uma
vez com o mestre violeiro conversando
com ele deu exemplo pra mim e achei
muito bonito onde falou o pedro se uma
árvore morre se a raiz da árvore morre
ela despenca ela não se sustenta
o folclore é isso foi por essa raiz que
sustenta toda a nossa identidade e nosso
governo ainda é muito precário nisso o
exemplo de alguns países existem já esse
olhar de conscientização da sobre a
importância do folclore uma estação num
programa de tv
eles estavam um entrevistado na suíça o
entrevistaram um produtor rural que
produzir queijo que o queijo suíço
tradicional e mostrou todo o
procedimento esse preparo de riqueza que
ele trazia pela forma intencional nada
mecanizado
desde quando tiro leite o tempo que o
queijo fica descansando e ficava numa
forma de madeira que era tirada do mangá
abre uma casca de árvore específica
super trabalhoso ea repórter chegou e
perguntou mas compensa financeiramente
você produzir isso né
ele respondeu é compensa porque eu
recebo pela venda dos terrenos é o
resultado que já fenomenal mas o governo
ele me paga uma velha é a mãe pega é
todo mês eu continuar produzindo
da mesma forma sem mecanizar ele me paga
inclusive para manter a estética da
minha fazenda
sabe aquela paisagem bonita que a gente
vê aquelas casinhas cobertas de neve das
paredes dos cartões postais da
da suíça o governo paga esse produtor
manter essa estrutura
quando vi essa notícia fiquei muito
surpresa com a gente mas chique como é
bonito essa consciência que eles têm de
manter viva a tradição do país porque
eles sabem que nós nesse produtor rural
está lá no interior fazendo essa
produção
ele está na verdade mantendo série na
essência do povo
ele é um dos que mantêm viva a história
dele é isso que o nosso governo peca né
ao deixar as nossas manifestações meio
de lado
eu pergunto a vocês que seria nem ea
sobre a ação dessa a questão da
identidade
eu convido você a pensar e repensar uma
identidade nacional
vamos pensar numa identidade familiar
em vez de pensar macro vamos pensar
menor do ano um grupo social menor que a
família se á se cada um que conhece a
sua história da família de onde veio o
pai a mãe o avô avó
cada família tem sua tradição tem seus
costumes têm a sua celebração tem as
suas cerimônias
e é isso que faz vocês entenderem
enquanto pessoa
a regalia sua história imagina você não
conhece assim nada não conhece onde você
veio né quem são ou qual a história da
sua família e dá uma sensação de ter
perdido no ambiente
o paralelo isso a gente pode fazer uma
relação com o folclore que é o folclore
que faz a gente ter essa identidade do
que é ser brasileiro o que é ser
realmente é pertencente a esse país como
uma nação e um caminho para a mudança
disse para a gente ter um olhar
diferente sobre o folclore não tenho
dúvidas que o conhecimento que a gente
trabalhar com educação
a partir do momento que o povo conhece a
sua história conhece as suas tradições
a gente pode mudar o olhar de futuro e
eu queria dar dois exemplos que que
aconteceram não é queijo vocês vão saber
um é das olimpíadas em 2016
foi um momento para todo mundo que é
pesquisador de folclore das tradições
populares das olimpíadas foi muito
interessante que foi o momento que o
brasil foi colocado em xeque a prova na
olimpíada na abertura das olimpíadas o
país-sede surpresa
né e aí o brasil ia ter que se olhar a
gente já tem que buscar nas nossas
transições para poder apresentar então
foi uma expectativa e por sorte foi
muito bonito
mostro naquela abertura da loja com
restrita mas mostrou um pouco da nossa
história um pouco dos nossos ritmos e
foi nítido ver a reação das pessoas né
depois dos comentários na internet em
bate-papo as pessoas comentando com
orgulho de ter visto o seu país sendo
representados teve sua história sendo
apresentado pelo mundo
então isso despertou tanto em muitas
pessoas essa alegria de ser brasileiro
não se eu faço parte disso eu nem sabia
que o país tinha tudo isso né
e aí começa a despertar a curiosidade né
sobre o que é uma outra situação e num
exemplo de franca no a gente tem um
espaço no centro cultural que engloba
que é um espaço de pesquisa e produção
das tradições populares da cultura
popular brasileira
dentre as atividades que a gente faz a
gente trabalha com maracatu de baque
virado num ritmo tradicional de
pernambuco que do que faz parte do ciclo
carnavalesco em 2007
a gente fez a primeira saída nossa com o
cortejo de maracatu
nem no carnaval e foi muito engraçado
ver a reação das pessoas se elas olhavam
aquele grupo de pessoas que é um grupo
pequeno tokano e era um monge maluco
tocando na rua né
era um olhar de estranhamento olhar de
nós que é isso muita gente fechar a
janela
ninguém acompanhava o porteiro pouquinho
as pessoas seguiam a gente tocando mas a
gente não desistiu a gente continuou o
trabalho em 2008 a coisa foi aumentando
e foi passando o tempo durante o ano
todo a gente fazendo trabalho com
oficinas com crianças com professores
saindo tocando fazendo apresentações em
praças escolas centros comunitários e
com o tempo essa assim esse olhar foi se
modificando até 2014 a gente montou um
bloco de carnaval que a essência do
bloco é o trabalho com as com os ritmos
tradicionais do carnaval brasileiro não
só o maracatu maracatus
a marchinha ou samba reto e chá em 2014
já tinham mais 500 pessoas acompanhando
no ano seguinte já foi para 1500 do
outro ano 3 mil ea coisa foi pegando
corpo até chegar nesse ano foi um cada
dia de sair dois dias com 7 mil pessoas
o que se dá nisso pra mim foi apresentar
esse conteúdo
o que antes era um olhar de
estranhamento é que as pessoas olhavam
não conheciam aquilo começou a ser
familiar deixou de ser estranho então
não tenho dúvida que o conhecimento é o
que move tudo o que está acontecendo
aqui hoje por exemplo a gente tem essa
essa prova aqui pode modificar alguma
coisa deve se alguém foi embora pensando
nossa não folclore não é só o saci eo
popular não né
de repente alguém que tem um familiar
próximo meu parente ele toca uma folia
de reis eu nunca pensei nisso né que
poderia ter salvo do valor pra ele assim
a a escola
eu acredito que é o centro maior de de
formação a equipe poderia desenvolver um
trabalho eo trabalho com foco na escola
ainda é muito muito muito restrito
isso acho que uma das causas de todo
mundo aqui quando falam fora todo mundo
pensar lendas porque a escola
infelizmente de semana e só essa essa
linha de pensamento chegou o dia 22 de
agosto o projeto folclore escola enche
de cartaz das lindas né
saci e música cabeça de todo mundo sair
pensando smo e aí eu penso que poderia
ser muito muito diferente em vez do
folclore é um projeto que poderia ser um
processo na verdade um processo
constante de busca do autoconhecimento
como brasileiro
a escola poderia incentivar na verdade
fazer cada aluno nem desenvolver dentro
daquele ambiente o orgulho de ser
brasileiro e identificar suas raízes
por exemplo na festa junina muitas
escolas já vi acontecer isso de falar
nossa festa junina que não trabalha
continuar nossa maior festa caipira a
nossa festa country que nada mais é
pepira norte-americano para mostrar como
que a gente tenha tendência de valorizar
o pé de fora né ea festa - é uma coisa
nossa tem que valorizar a cultura
caipira a gente aqui na nossa região
dentro da cultura caipira e perdido
muitas vezes é usado como um xingamento
seja perceber isso é o cúmulo de
desvalorização o que a essência da nossa
cultura
já vi professores acontecendo isso
olhando lá o bagulho caipira
claro que é nós somos caipiras não somos
descendentes assim como tem o
descendente da cultura caiçara
quilombola e assim por diante
então é trabalhar essa consciência do
orgulho de ser brasileiro
constantemente não só no dia 22 de
agosto
pensar o tempo inteiro da importância de
desenvolver nossa identidade
a gente se valorizar e é só assim
desenvolver a nossa identidade que a
gente vai se fortalecendo contra nação
para bater no peito e tenho orgulho de
ser brasileiro e aí pra mim o estudo de
folclore poderia se resumir em uma
palavra numa nova fase que é o que é ser
brasileiro que fazem se entender
enquanto o brasileiro deixa a questão
pra vocês agradeço muito a atenção aí
obrigado mesmo
[Aplausos]